hey guys Pete here are you ready to look
at the final two episodes of mr. robot
because I am and this is going to be my
mr. robot season 3 episode 9 recap and
review I wasn't around to make the final
two videos and now I'm gonna be doing
that today and tomorrow overall I think
the season ended off good but I have to
say that episode 9 was not my favorite
episode of the season it was good at
doing what it needed to do and that was
gonna set up for the finale but it was
just a lot of stuff that all happened
and it kind of got muddied up there I
think I mean so much stuff happened that
a little bit of it seemed kind of
unbelievable but there was also some
really fantastic parts I mean III think
season 3 has been great and part of the
reason why this episode is not the
greatest is because it has so much
competition so the episode is called
stage 3 dot torrent that is because
Elliott decides to go after the dark
army and he uses a ruse that there's a
stage 3 in order to get a meeting and
get some corrupted files on to the dark
armies Network we also see Darlene get
picked up by the FBI and that's where
everything started as mr. robot tells us
via a bar of soap on the mirror they own
the FBI so the episode starts there
Elliott's trying to figure out what mr.
robot found out when he took over and we
go back and forth between present time
and flashbacks that show what mr. robot
actually found out in the end what he
finds out is is that the dark army is
actually worse than a corp or evil Corp
as it is and that everything they did
was pretty much for nothing and that's
all good by me because I mean that's
sort of what this season boiled down to
is that the good guys got screwed
because the real people in control get
what they want and people in positions
like mr. robot and Elliot their split
personality there are the ones who take
the fall and lose everything they have
like one of the things I really like
about this episode is by the end
it is essentially alone everybody that
was on his side has been neutralized
except for mr. robot which he
neutralized himself so that was my my
big takeaway from the whole thing was is
that it's Elliot vs. dark army in the
next episode what I thought was too thin
though was the fact that Elliot was able
to own the dark army so simply like I
guess he could kind of think like well
they thought they were in control so
they didn't see they thought they were
taking his computer from him and all
that but it seems like a pretty simple
way for him to get control of their
network and a lot of stuff has to happen
to get us to that point where Elliot is
indeed alone we have to see Tyrell is
screwed we have to see that Darlene is
caught we have to see that Angela is out
of her mind which was also kind of a fun
part of the episode I thought but it's
just like so many things happen it
didn't have the flow that I was getting
used to in season 3 I guess so how does
Tyrell find out that he's nobody all of
a sudden that nothing that he thought
was gonna happen he wasn't gonna be free
that he didn't get out of this clear
even though Johanna had died well that
all comes down and when mr. robot goes
to visit him he's basically ready to
kill him or at least beat him senseless
and Phillip price shows up and well this
wasn't the best part of that episode I
wouldn't say like what he says there is
pretty definitive price knew about
everything that was happening because of
white rose and he says world
catastrophes like this they aren't
caused by lone wolves like you he's
telling this to mr. robot who he thinks
is Elliot they aren't caused by lone
Wolf's like you they occur because men
like me allow them you just happened to
stumble into one so this is a
continuation kind of of what Irving was
telling mr. robot a few episodes ago
where he takes him and he shows him that
party and he says look these people are
still having a party they're still
celebrating because that's what they do
he's going there to clean up and fix the
situation of someone overdosing and all
that but it doesn't matter these people
because they are just busy pulling the
strings and while price is there he is
been painted as the enemy he's
CEO of evil Corp but we find out that
even him like he's not immune from it
because the whole time the dark army has
been behind everything we get a bit of a
flashback to when evil Corp actually
decided to hire all safe it's kind of
played out like maybe Christ saw
something in Angela that he liked can't
really go into it any further here
because that'd be spoilers for the next
episode but as far as the scope of this
episode it seemed a little bit
unnecessary to me I mean we saw that
Terry Colby was a douche bag again we
knew that already and meanwhile we get
back to Trenton's email and we find out
that Elliot needs to get into Sentinel
which is the FBI's clothes Network and
Darlene has a plan in the end I was glad
that Darlene wasn't able to pull that
off I think it would have been a little
bit too cheesy if she did that and
Elliot owned the dark army and they just
walked off in the sunset obviously I
think that whole scene was pretty well
acted by both Carley Chaiken and Grace
Gummer I thought that was a pretty good
scene I don't know I mean we kind of we
knew that Dom was lonely obviously that
was a big part of her character's
backstory
would she have fallen for Darlene I mean
there was definitely indications that
that might happen earlier on and fans
were definitely theorizing on it I guess
it worked okay like I said I'm glad that
it didn't end up being what it had the
making of like her getting away with it
and getting away with that badge so yeah
that lands Darlene in the FBI's
headquarters being interrogated and we
know that Tom's boss Santiago is working
for the dark army so he's got a problem
he races out to Irving who is cool and
collected even when he gets his car shut
down by OnStar by Eliot and he just
asked his potential customer to go ahead
back to the car lot and he'll meet her
there that of course opens the door for
Eliot to meet up with Grant white roses
assistant and he plants the malware and
that gets him into the
Urmi system so as mentioned I think it
does a great job of setting up the
finale and what's interesting to me I
went back and watched it a second time
because it had been a while before I got
to make the video since I watched it the
first time at night I kind of thought
about it in a different way you know
Elliott everything set up for Elliott
versus the dark army and originally I
was thinking about it like it was
Elliott versus White Rose but it's
really not it's Elliott versus Grant
right we got that scene where she gives
him control and lets him do what he
wants to do and he has a particularly
unhealthy obsession with making Elliott
fail I think they do a pretty good job
of painting that picture you know he
thinks that if you if he would have just
he I mean he tells White Rose if you
just had done what I said and done my
plan instead of putting so much faith in
Elliott everything would be different
and I thought it was pretty funny I
think one of the best parts of it was
that as they're talking you know she
switches back and starts talking Chinese
and I was thinking about the fact that
earlier in the season he only spoke
Chinese remember she said to him that
you know I think now that you're doing
this you need to learn English and that
was not that long ago so he has perfect
English now and I didn't even catch that
until I saw this ending scene here but
things are set up Elliott's lost it all
he has a way to fix the hack but not
necessarily anything beyond that I don't
even really know what we're supposed to
suspect will happen if he does that but
you know we see the fatal flaw in that
the FBI does not have the same intention
because of Santiago so we're set up for
the finale it was a good episode a lot
of stuff came together it just seemed a
little bit rushed to me I don't know
what you guys think you can tell me in
the comments I will be doing the finale
recap and review right after this so be
on the lookout for that tomorrow sorry
about being away but I had to earn some
cash to pay my bills and I wasn't
getting that done
through YouTube last month so just
something that had to happen definitely
give this video a like if you enjoyed it
if you want to see more videos like this
think about joining my patreon so that I
can continue to do what I do make sure
you subscribe to my channel and turn on
notifications so that you'll know when
new videos come out over a patreon I'm
gonna be talking to my patrons there to
see what we can do I'm in between shows
it looks like West world's gonna be
coming out in April or sometime around
then so gonna have to figure out
something to work on between now and
then and I give my patreon patrons the
biggest say and how that goes because
they help to support the channel
in the meantime that's it for now thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon